lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
repasar el concepto de composición de
funciones y luego vamos a desarrollar
algunas habilidades reconociendo como
las funciones pueden estar compuestas si
nunca se ha escuchado el término de
funciones compuestas o si los primeros
minutos de este vídeo no son nada
familiares para ti entonces te invito a
que ver los vídeos de álgebra sobre
composición de funciones en la canaca de
mí el objetivo de este vídeo es que sea
un poco de práctica antes de que
entremos en algunas habilidades que son
necesarias en cálculo y en particular en
la regla de la cadena así que vamos a
dar un repaso sobre lo que es una
función compuesta voy a definir dos
funciones
fd x es igual a 1 + x y por otra parte
voy a definir a la función de x como el
coseno de
entonces quién sería efe
compuesta de gd x f de g d
y te invito a que pausa este vídeo e
intentas trabajarlo por tu cuenta bien
una manera de plantearlo es la siguiente
la entrada de fx dejará de ser equis y
pasar a ser gtx así que en donde sea que
veamos una equis en la definición de fx
la vamos a reemplazar con g de
entonces efe deje de x va a ser igual a
1 más y en lugar de que la entrada sea x
vamos a poner como entrada a gtx
entonces la salida va a ser uno más gtx
y bueno que de x por supuesto sabemos
que es el coste no de x así que en lugar
de gtx podré escribir uno más el coseno
de x
ahora una forma de ver esto es que
primero estoy poniendo mi x en gdx
entonces xv a la función g y sale como
gtx y luego tomamos esa salida de x y
metemos eso en mi función
efe dándonos así efe de cualquiera que
sea la entrada pero como la entrada g de
x me va a quedar
efe deje de x así que siguiendo con este
repaso veamos si podemos ir a otro lado
veamos si podemos buscar algún tipo de
definición de una función y decir que
podemos expresar eso como una
composición de otras funciones digamos
que tengo a ver una gtx que voy a
ponerle el nombre de ccoo seno de el
seno de x más 1 ok y también quiero
decir que muchas veces hay más de una
manera de componer o construir una
función basada en la composición de
otras funciones ok
dicho esto pausa en el vídeo y digan
puedo expresar a gd x como una
composición de otras
funciones digamos de las funciones de x
y de x bueno hay un par de maneras en
las que pueden plantear esto podrán
decir que estás si llamo al seno de x de
x
entonces esto sería el coche no de de x
+ 1 y después puedo definir otra función
como vd x siendo igual al coseno de
cualquiera que sea su entrada más 1
entonces esto parece ser la composición
debe de x y vx y en lugar de bt x
hicimos ver de o de x y entonces esto
nos quedaría como el cocedero de de x +
1 y así justo permítanme escribir acá
abajo me quedaría bem de de x que es el
seno de x entonces esto va a ser igual
al coseno en lugar de x más 1 voy a
poner de x + 1
pero como ud x es el seno de x es más
terca que escribirlo por aquí de x es el
seno de x así es como lo establecimos
entonces podemos escribir esto como el
coseno de ud x más 1 o el coseno de seno
de x más uno que es exactamente lo que
teníamos antes
entonces si decimos que ud x es el seno
de x ivd x es el coseno de x más uno
ahora si podemos escribir a gdx como la
composición de estas dos funciones ahora
incluso podrían hacer una composición de
tres funciones podemos mantener como x
igual al seno de x y ahora vamos a
definir a
de x esto es igual
bueno mi entrada ya no es x entonces en
lugar de x voy a poner de x y me va a
quedar igual a de x + 1 o lo puedo ver
cómo se nos dé x 1 y luego si definimos
una tercera función no sean se me
ocurren hdx como coseno de lo que sea su
entrada es decir él posee no de x bien
entonces se observa quienes h de w
de x bueno pues eso va a ser gdx
permíteme escribirlo acá abajo h dm w
d
de x esto va a ser igual a bueno
recuerden que se toma el coche no de
cualquiera que sea su entrada pero ahora
su entrada es w
dv x entonces ya no se encuentra de ww x
recuerdas eso es lo mismo que el seno de
x + 1
entonces me quedaría el co seno del seno
de x + 1 donde ud x es el seno de x hoy
lo podemos ver también de esta manera ud
x es el seno de x eso lo introdujimos en
w
entonces me quedaría el seno de x más
uno y luego eso lo introdujimos en h&m
para obtener el coseno del seno de x + 1
lo cual claro es nuestra expresión
original que es igual a g así que toda
esta cuestión de aquí es para apreciar
cómo reconocer la composición de las
funciones ojo quiero recalcar que no
siempre se trata de una composición de
funciones es más déjame quitar todo esto
y vamos a hacer otro ejemplo más si
tengo una función no sé se me ocurre
poner a fx como el coche
x por el seno de x sería difícil de
expresar esto como una composición de
funciones pero puede representarlo en
este caso como el producto de funciones
por ejemplo puede decir que ud x sea el
coseno de x y puedo decir que pd x sea
el seno de x entonces aquí
fx no sería la composición de idv sería
el producto de de x por b de x eso sería
fx si tuviéramos que sacar la
composición por ejemplo si pienso en un
dvd x bueno pausa el vídeo y piensa a
qué me refiero con eso
esto es un poco de repaso bien ud x es
el co seno de cualquiera que sea su
entrada y ahora su entrada es de x lo
cual es el seno de x
entonces el coseno del seno de x es un
dvd equis y luego qué pasa si hacen de
dvd x bueno sería lo mismo pero al revés
sería el seno del coseno de x pero en
cualquier caso esto es sólo para
ayudarnos a reconocer cuando tengo una
expresión o una definición de una
función que sea el producto de dos
funciones y cuando tengo la composición
de dos funciones y de hecho algunas
veces puedes estar buscando productos de
composiciones o conscientes de
composiciones o todo tipo de diferentes
combinaciones de cómo pueden juntar
funciones para crear nuevas funciones